You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water.
你曾说这里离水面只有几步远。我们只是还没找到那几步在哪儿。我们省了多少钱？够了。够去浪迹天涯了！或者你也可以在希尔顿预订房间。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。距离水面仅数步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. If you've ever had to clean out someone's home after they died, you probably discovered that people save strange and random things. I recently helped clear out my dad's home and found, for example,
希尔顿特惠活动正在进行中。在希尔顿官网或希尔顿App预订，最高可省20%，享受你期待的住宿体验。当你追求实惠而非惊吓时。住哪里很关键。希尔顿，悦斯之本。如果你曾帮别人在他们去世后清理过他们的家，你可能会发现人们会留存一些奇怪且随意的物品。我最近帮忙清理了我父亲的家，比如我发现里头有
the sales contract for the house he bought in 1957, my late mother's violin dating to her years in high school, and all my and my brother's elementary school report cards. These are things that made sense from a sentimental viewpoint, and they didn't take up a lot of space. But what about people who save huge quantities of things with no apparent value that have no sentimental meaning, and in the eyes of most people, will be trash? Can saving too much stuff be pathological? Where is the line between being a messy housekeeper and having a hoarding disorder? What drives some people to save enormous quantities of indiscriminate things. And is such behavior merely a manifestation of something like obsessive compulsive disorder or is it a discrete mental illness? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology,
他1957年买房时的销售合同、我已故母亲高中时期的长笛，还有我和我弟弟所有的所有小学成绩单。从情感角度来看，这些都是合乎情理的物品，而且它们并不占用太多空间。但是，那些积攒了大量看似毫无价值、没有情感意义，并且在大多数人眼里就是垃圾的东西的人呢？囤积太多东西会是一种病态吗？做个邋遢的管家与患上囤积症之间的界限在哪里？是什么驱使某些人囤积大量不加选择的物品？这种行为仅仅是强迫症之类的表现，还是是一种独立的精神疾病？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，
the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Mary E. Dozier, a licensed clinical psychologist and an assistant professor at Mississippi State University Her research focuses on evidence-based methods of assessment and treatment for psychopathology across the lifespan, including hoarding disorder in older adults. More recently, she's branched out to study hoarding disorder in younger people. Dr. Dosier has developed some protocols for helping people who have hoarding disorder, which we will talk about today.
这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是玛丽·E·多齐尔博士，她是一名持证临床心理学家兼密西西比州立大学助理教授。她的研究重点是针对全生命周期精神病理学的循证评估和治疗方法，包括老年人的囤积症。最近，她将研究范围扩大到了年轻人群体的囤积症。多齐尔博士开发了一些协议来帮助患有囤积症的人，我们今天将对此进行讨论。
Dr. Dosier, thank you for joining me. Thank you so much for having me. Let's start with the definition, what exactly. is hoarding disorder? Is it in the DSM? And how is it different from just being messy or indifferent to clutter? Yes, that's a wonderful question. So it's actually a relatively new addition to the DSM. So our latest edition came out in 2013, and that's when hoarding disorder was added as a discrete disorder. So before that, it was considered part of obsessive-compulsive disorder or just a symptom secondary to other disorders like schizophrenia or autism or even major depression. But after 2013, we've been able to
多齐尔博士，非常感谢你做客节目。非常感谢邀请我。让我们从定义开始，究竟什么是囤积症？它被收录在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中吗？它与单纯的邋遢或对杂乱无章无动于衷有什么区别？是的，这是一个很好的问题。其实它是DSM中一个比较新的收录。我们最新版是在2013年发布的，也就是在那时，囤积症作为一种独立的疾病被添加进来。在此之前，它被认为是强迫症的一部分，或者是其他疾病（如精神分裂症、自闭症甚至重度抑郁症）的继发症状。但在2013年之后，我们能够
talk about hoarding disorder as its own distinct category. So what really lets us know that people have problems with hoarding is kind of like you said in the intro, where the clutter level gets to the point that people aren't able to use their homes the way they would like to anymore, that the clutter has become impairing. And so that's with the physical manifestation. But our psychological manifestation comes from difficulty discarding ordinary things that other people might be able to get rid of, as well as a need to hold onto things that other people wouldn't see the need to hold on to. What drives people to hoard? And you mentioned other psychological problems that people might have. So, I mean, how are they associated? How do they sort of work together in the
将囤积症作为一个独特的类别来讨论。那么，真正让我们知道人们有囤积问题的是，就像你在开场白中说的那样，杂乱程度达到了人们不再能像以前那样使用他们的家，杂乱已经造成了损害。这就是身体上的表现。但我们的心理表现来自于难以丢弃其他人可能能够处理掉的普通物品，以及保留其他人看不到有必要保留的物品的需求。是什么驱使人们囤积？你提到了人们可能患有的其他心理问题。所以，我的意思是，它们是如何关联的？它们是如何在
brain? Yeah, we see a lot of the reward pathways being activated with hoarding. So I think all of us or many of us have had the joy of going shopping and seeing something, you know, a new sweater that you really like. And you have that sense of almost accomplishment of I found something good. And if you think about folks with excessive acquisition problems, it's like that but magnified. And so anything that comes into the home can really make them feel good as kind of a coping strategy. We also see that just normal things that other people might not see the need to hold onto, folks with hoarding problems will. So, for example, junk mail is something that all of us
大脑中协同作用的？是的，我们在囤积中看到许多奖励通路的激活。所以我想我们所有人或许多人都体验过去购物并看到某样东西的快乐，你知道，一件你真的很喜欢的崭新毛衣。你会有那种几乎是成就感的感觉：我找到了好东西。如果你想想那些有过度获得问题的人，这就类似于那种感觉，但被放大了。因此，任何进入家里的东西都能真正让他们感觉良好，作为一种应对策略。我们还看到，其他人可能认为没有必要保留的普通东西，有囤积问题的人却会保留。例如，垃圾邮件是我们所有人都
bring into our home. And so somebody without hoarding problems might sort through that on a pretty regular basis. Like, I'll confess for me sometimes every other day. But somebody with hoarding problems, those things come into the home and they don't leave. And that's where the clutter starts to build up to the point where it becomes unmanageable. How prevalent is this problem? So it's more prevalent than most people think. So it's about 2% in the general population, but we actually see that it increases in prevalence over the lifespan. So for most psychological disorders, we see a decrease over the lifespan that generally
会带进家里的东西。因此，没有囤积问题的人可能会相当定期地对这些东西进行分类。比如，我承认对我来说有时每两天一次。但对于有囤积问题的人来说，这些东西进入了家里就再也没有离开过。这就是杂乱开始堆积到无法控制的地步的地方。这个问题有多普遍？所以它比大多数人想象的要普遍。在总人口中约为2%，但我们实际上发现它在整个生命周期中的患病率会增加。所以对于大多数心理疾病，我们看到患病率在生命周期中会下降，通常
we think of older adults as having better emotion regulation. But for hoarding, we actually see that folks in their 70s have about a 7% prevalence rate for hoarding. So it's very likely that the folks listening today know someone in their life. who's struggling with clutter. And it might not be something they used to struggle with, but as they've gotten older, it's become something that keeps them from using their home. Do people with hoarding disorder tend to live alone, or are they more likely to live with others, whether that's, say, a partner who tolerates the behavior or, say, children who are powerless
我们认为老年人有更好的情绪调节能力。但对于囤积，我们实际上发现70多岁的人群中囤积的患病率约为7%。所以今天听节目的听众很可能会认识生活中的某个人，他们正在与杂乱作斗争。这可能不是他们曾经挣扎过的事情，但随着他们年龄的增长，它已经成为阻碍他们使用自己家的问题。患有囤积症的人往往独自居住，还是更有可能与他人同居，无论是说能够容忍这种行为的伴侣，还是无力
to stop it? Yeah, that actually is something that depends a lot on where they live, who are finding. And so I initially did my work out in San Diego and graduate school. And most of our folks that we worked with were single and had never been married. And these were older adults. That's just the fact that they had hoarding problems kept people from being in their lives. But now I'm in rural Mississippi. And what we find here is that folks are able to have more space. And because of that, they're more likely to have a spouse or somebody else who's able to live with them.
阻止它的孩子？是的，这实际上在很大程度上取决于他们住在哪里，我们发现了什么。所以我最初是在圣地亚哥读研究生时开展工作的。我们合作过的大多数人都是单身，从未结过婚。而且这些都是老年人。仅仅是他们有囤积问题这个事实就阻碍了其他人进入他们的生活。但现在我在密西西比州的农村。我们在这里发现的是，人们能够拥有更多空间。正因为如此，他们更有可能拥有配偶或其他人能够与他们同居。
The idea is that the underlying psychopathology, that difficulty discarding your problems with acquisition might be the same, but the clutter, if it's able to be spread out, can be less impairing on a daily basis. And so you're more likely to have loved ones that are able to be in your life. So based on what you've just said, it does make sense that the stereotype of people who hoard are older, and depending on where they live, they may be solitary, but they may not be. but you've also begun studying younger people with hoarding disorder. I'm just wondering, is there a profile of a typical person with hoarding disorder, whether that's based on sex or socioeconomic status or other demographics,
这个想法是，潜在的精神病理学，即难以丢弃你的问题和获取问题可能是相同的，但杂乱，如果能够分散开来，在日常生活中造成的损害就会小一些。因此，你更有可能让所爱的人能够进入你的生活。因此，根据你刚才所说，有囤积倾向的人年龄偏大这种刻板印象确实说得通，而且根据他们居住的地方，他们可能是独居，也可能不是；但你也开始研究患有囤积症的年轻人。我只是想知道，是否存在一个典型囤积症患者的画像，无论是基于性别、社会经济地位还是其他人口统计特征，
and are there certain personality traits that are associated with hoarding disorder? Yeah, so I'll answer that last part first of some of the research I've done here in Mississippi has actually found that pretty much universally, the folks you've been working with have really high rates of altruism, which fits with what I see clinically, that often folks with hoarding problems will say, you know, I'm holding onto these things for a reason. I'm holding onto these things because I want to give it to somebody else. Or I would be able to get rid of my pencil collection if I knew they could go to children who need pencils, right? That it's holding onto things out of this sense of responsibility to the items or to other folks. And even
并且是否存在某些与囤积症相关的人格特质？是的，所以我先回答最后一部分，我在密西西比州做的一些研究实际上发现，几乎普遍来说，你一直在合作的人有非常高的利他主义比率，这符合我在临床上看到的，即通常有囤积问题的人会说，你知道，我保留这些东西是有原因的。我保留这些东西是因为我想把它给别人。或者如果我知道我的铅笔可以送给需要铅笔的孩子，我就能扔掉我的铅笔收藏，对吧？也就是说，出于对物品或对其他人的这种责任感而保留东西。甚至
things like I've had folks that seemingly have what looks like trash, but they say, no, like, this is something that could be recycled. I just need to figure out how to recycle it. And that sometimes kind of secondary of something that we see is that organizational problems can be pretty endemic in folks with hoarding problems, which can lead to a barrier to discarding, right? That they might have a very specific way that they want to get rid of something, but it's the follow-through that can become difficult.
像我曾遇到过一些人，他们手里拿的东西看起来像垃圾，但他们会说，不，像，这是可以回收的东西。我只需要弄清楚如何回收它。有时这就像是我们看到的一种次要的东西，即组织问题在有囤积问题的人当中可能是根深蒂固的，这可能会导致丢弃的障碍，对吧？他们可能有一种非常具体的方式想要摆脱某样东西，但执行力可能会变得困难。
And with that, we actually see a fairly high-rength. rate of comorbidity with ADHD. Sometimes folks with ADHD who don't necessarily have hoarding problems, it can almost look that way because of disorganization in their lives. And then the other kind of main comorbidity will often see is major depression. So about 30% of folks with major depressive disorder also have hoarding disorder and vice versa. And I think the link there comes with feelings of apathy, of that and just in terms of motivation, of an inability to get oneself sort of out of bed and to do things like take out the trash, like sort through junk mail. So going back to my question that had too many questions embedded, is there a profile based on
随之而来的是，我们实际上看到与多动症（ADHD）的共病率相当高。有时患有多动症但并不一定有囤积问题的人，由于他们生活中的无组织状态，几乎看起来是那样的。然后我们经常看到的另一种主要的共病将是重度抑郁症。因此，大约30%患有重度抑郁障碍的人也患有囤积症，反之亦然。我认为其中的联系来自于冷漠感，也就是在动力方面，无法让自己从床上起来并做一些诸如倒垃圾、整理垃圾邮件之类的事情。所以回到我那个包含太多问题的问题，是否存在一个基于
sex, socioeconomic status or other demographics? So we tend to see it more frequently in women, which is true generally of psychological disorders. And so there's always that tricky part of, is it actually more prevalent in women or is that because women are more likely to present for treatment. And we do tend to see it more in older folks. And then the sad part about it, and I think where a lot of the stigma comes from, is that hoarding is often associated with poverty. And that's especially something that we see in rural areas
性别、社会经济地位或其他人口统计特征的画像？所以我们往往看到它在女性中更常见，心理疾病通常也是如此。所以总是有那个棘手的部分，即它在女性中真的更普遍，还是因为女性更有可能寻求治疗。我们确实倾向于在老年人中看到更多。然后关于它令人悲伤的部分，也是我认为很多污名化的来源，那就是囤积通常与贫困联系在一起。这特别是在农村地区看到的情况，
where they're able to just keep adding onto the home or put it another shed. And I think that's where, again, a lot of the stigma comes from. And so I think, you know, the folks who struggle most with hoarding in terms of the consequences to their health are going to be be people who are poor. Tell us about the research you've done with younger people with hoarding disorder. I mean, how do you identify younger people when maybe they don't even have a house yet? So how do you know that they're headed down that path? Yeah, so this is actually a relatively new avenue of research for me that came about with the graduate student who's particularly
在那里他们能够不断给房子加盖或者建另一个棚屋。我认为这也就是很多污名化的来源。所以我认为，你知道，在健康后果方面受囤积困扰最严重的人将是穷人。跟我们讲讲你对患有囤积症的年轻人群体开展的研究。我的意思是，当年轻人可能甚至还没有房子时，你是如何识别他们的？那么你怎么知道他们正在走向那条路呢？是的，这实际上对我来说是一个相对较新的研究方向，它源于一位对新兴成人特别感兴趣的研究生，以及我们如何能够阻止囤积在晚年造成如此严重的后果。所以我们正在研究的是我们是否能进行早期干预。因此，我们让密西西比州立大学的本科生进行自我识别，看看自己是否存在获取问题或杂乱问题，然后让他们参加小组设定，我们在其中教授有关组织以及如何放手物品的技能。因此，思考物体依恋是我们进行干预的地方。也就是帮助人们看到他们与物品之间可以有更多的距离。这也回到了获取通常对我们所有人都感觉良好的观点，
interested in emerging adults and how we can stop hoarding from becoming so consequential in late life. And so what we're looking at is if we can have an early intervention. So we've been having undergraduates here at Mississippi State self-identifies having problems with either acquisition or clutter and then enrolling them in a group setting where we both teach skills around organization and around how one can let go of things. So thinking about object attachment is kind of the place where we're intervening. So helping folks to see that there can be more distance between themselves and items. And also back to the idea that acquisition generally feels good for all of us,
即帮助人们想出其他应对策略。所以当你感觉到那种我真的想通过买东西让自己感觉更好的感觉时，你在此期间还能做些什么来让那种感觉消失？囤积如何影响囤积者的孩子和其他家庭成员？当他们长大后，这些孩子是否也往往会囤积？还是他们变成了洁癖？是的，这是一个很好的问题。所以囤积绝对是我们看到的一种现象。
of helping folks to come up with what are other coping strategies. So when you feel that sense of I really want to make myself feel better by buying something, is there something else you can do in that meantime to let that feeling go? How does hoarding affect the children and other family members of people who hoard? And when they grow up, do these children tend to hoard as well? or do they become clean freaks? Yeah, so that's a great question. So hoarding is definitely something that we see.
它有一个相当强的遗传成分，即父母有囤积问题的人自己也更容易产生囤积问题。但我们也看到，往往会产生后果，即人们可能会与父母的关系更糟糕。但另一方面，我与加州人们所做的一些研究表明，人们往往仍然与他们患有囤积症的所爱之人保持着真正的关系。而且通常，即使感觉是一种负担，
There's a pretty strong genetic component to it in that folks who have parents that had hoarding problems are going to be more predisposed to having hoarding problems himself. But we also see that there tends to be consequences in that folks might maybe have worse relationships with their parents. But on the other side, some of the research I've done with folks back in California shows that people tend to still have really relationships with their loved ones with hoarding problems. And often, even if it feels like a burden,
仍然可能是他们从中发现很多回报的事情。我想稍微谈谈治疗。你对人们的家进行亲自动手的干预，对吧，并试图让他们缓和自己的行为？你是怎么做的，进展如何？你是如何达到成功点的？所以现在我从美国心理学基金会以及国家心理健康研究所获得了资金支持。我们正在研究的是一种干预措施，就像你说的，我们每周去他们家一次。这个想法是我们要成为一个中立的、积极的存在。不幸的是，在试图帮助人们丢弃东西时，亲人往往没那么可爱，对吧？通常，你知道，我们进去和父母谈话，可能带着我们自己的
can still be something that they find a lot of reward out of. I want to talk a little bit about treatment. You do hands-on sessions with people in their homes, right, and trying to get them to moderate their behavior. What do you do and how does it progress? How do you reach a point of success? So I've gotten funding now from the American Psychological Foundation as well as the National Institute of Mental Health. And what we're looking at is an intervention where, like you said, we go to their home once a week. And the idea is that we're being a neutral, positive presence. So unfortunately, so often loved ones can be a little less than lovely when trying to help people discard, right? That often, you know, we go in and talk to our parents and might have our own needs.
关于他们应该保留和丢弃什么的看法。因此，拥有一个没有自己关于物品或发现的看法的白纸一般的人，实际上对激励这个人非常有帮助。所以我们的功能是双重的。一是给这个人几乎是许可去占用那个空间，占用那一个小时去储存并在没有评判的情况下丢弃东西。其次，我们使用一种叫做动机访谈的技术，根据他们自己的价值观帮助他们讨论是否想要保留和丢弃物品。所以再次回到这一点，这完全是他们个人认为重要而需要保留的东西。我们发现这往往是对人们来说非常有效的干预措施，他们既能够在
ideas of what they should keep and discard. And so having someone who's kind of a blank slate who doesn't have their own thoughts about items or finding can actually be really helpful to motivate the person. So our function is twofold. One is to give the person almost permission to take that space, take that hour to store it and discard things free of judgment. And then secondarily, we use something called motivational interviewing to help them talk through whether or not they want to keep and discard things based on their own values. So again, back to it, it's all what they personally think is important to keep. And what we found is that this tends to be a pretty effective intervention for folks, that they're able to both engage in the sorting
会话中参与分类，并且这增加了他们在会话之间进行分类的能力。对于许多精神疾病，有时它是某种疗法（也就是你所描述的那种）和某种药物的结合。这对于患有囤积症的人有用吗？对于囤积者来说，是否存在联合疗法？关于囤积治疗的研究，就囤积症本身而言，仍然有点新。已经有一些人做过药物试验，但我认为还没有进行太多关于药物结合疗法以了解什么最有效的研究。我想已经有一些人研究过，回到多动症的联系，研究一些多动症药物，看这是否有帮助，
in session and that it increases their ability to sort in between sessions. With a lot of mental disorders, sometimes it's a combination of a sort of therapy, which is sort of what you're describing, and some kind of a drug. Does that work with people who have hoarding disorder? Does there combination therapy for people who hoard? Research on the treatment of hoarding is still a little bit new in terms of hoarding disorder specifically. And there have been some people who have done drug trials, but I don't think there's been a lot yet of research looking at medication combined with therapy to see what would be most effective. I think there have been some folks who have actually looked at, so back to the connection of ADHD, looking at some ADHD medication, if that could be helped.
以及用于其他强迫症的SSRI类药物。我们将进行短暂的休息，回来后我们将继续与多齐尔博士讨论囤积症的疗法，以及你如何最好地帮助那些正在与杂乱作斗争的挚爱之人。这是授粉的高峰期，我的业务正在快速扩张。为了让花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择Google Fi Wireless的原因。我的连接始终强劲，即使在高发期也一样。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为35美元/月。这绝对是一笔不会错过的划算交易。
as well as FSRIs, which are used for other obsessive-compulsive disorders. We're going to take a short break, and when we return, we'll talk more with Dr. Dozier about treatments for hoarding disorder and how you can best help loved ones who are struggling with clutter. It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose GoogleFi wireless. My connections stay strong, even when the high-vis. is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay.
今天就来了解Google Fi Wireless套餐。需加收税费和政府规费。在网络流量高峰期，Google Fi Wireless不受数据流量降速限制。家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日特惠让你的夏天现在开始。是时候用Next Grill四燃烧器燃气烤架开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅需199美元。尽情狂欢一整个夏天，
Explore GoogleFi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees. Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season. with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499.99. This Memorial Day, get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, pricing invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details.
只需499.99美元即可购买Hampton Bay West Grove七件套户外餐桌椅。今年阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受保证低价。售完即止，价格有效期为5月14日至5月27日，仅限美国，特定条款适用。详情请参见HomeDepot.com/pricematch。如果你患有这种疾病，而你来到我的家中，我们将如何开始这个过程？你帮我断舍离会是什么样子的？是的。所以我们从询问你想从哪里开始开始，对吧？我对某人的部分目标是让他们从一个他们觉得自己可以取得进展的地方开始。我不想让第一次会议只是考虑，你知道的，比如一个杯子，对吧？如果我们把整个会议都用来考虑那个，你不会觉得你在会议结束时完成了一些事情。所以我们试图从一个那个人说的地方开始，我可以对这些东西进行分类并想出要丢弃的东西。
If I had the disorder and you were to come into my home, how would we start the process? What does it look like for you to help me to de-excession? Yes. So we start with just asking you where you want to start, right? And part of my goal for somebody is to have them start in a place where they feel like they can make progress. That I don't want the first session to be just thinking about, you know, like one cup, right? That if we spend all session thinking about that, you're not going to feel like you accomplish something at the end of the session. So we try to start in a place where the person says, I can sort through these things and come up with things to discard.
所以在那个会议结束时，他们可以说，我能够把这么多的东西带出家门。这完全是为了建立这种自我效能感和成就感。伴随这一点，实际上，如果人们在一个项目上花费太多时间，我们鼓励他们把它放在一边。所以我所做的一点与暴露疗法相反。我们不是让他们忍受痛苦。相反，我们专注于自我效能感，再次强调，他们在那段时间里可以分类多少东西。这种治疗通常需要多长时间？所以我们现在正在看的干预是16次会话，也就是每周一次，大约四个月。
So at the end of that session, they can say, I was able to get so much things out of the home. And it's all about building up that sense of self-efficacy and that sense of accomplishment. And with that, we actually, if folks are spending too much time on one item, we encourage them to set it aside. So it's a little bit what I do is the opposite of exposure therapy. We're not making them sit with the distress. Instead, we're focusing on the sense of self-afficacy, again, of how many things can they sort in that time. And how long does this treatment typically take? So the intervention we're looking at right now is 16 sessions, so once a week for about four months.
但我们也试行了6次会话的版本，虽然我们没有获得像在16周内获得那么多的收益，但我们能够在短短的时间内，实际上在积极情绪方面显著地推动人们。也就是增加他们的一般幸福感，以及减少他们对物品的依恋感。我们假设这两件事如果我们能够推动它们，它将使人们朝着那个方向继续前进。通常人们随着年龄的增长，会产生一种被他们的物品压倒的感觉。我们发现，如果我们能让人达到一个他们觉得自己可以自己开始的地方，对吧？这不是无法控制的，他们能够继续保持分类和丢弃的行为。从长远来看，这有多有效？我的意思是，你有机会在六个月后回去看看这个人是否处在同一个地方，还是在复发，还是已经进步了？这是一个很好的问题。我希望我能告诉你答案。对于我专门研究的干预，我们还没能做随访。但对于其他囤积干预，我们确实知道它们可以相当稳定，
But we've also piloted a six-session version that we didn't get as many gains as you get in 16 weeks, but we were able to, just in that amount of time, actually significantly move people in terms of positive affect. So increasing just their general feelings of well-being, as well as decreasing their sense of attachment to items. which are two things that we hypothesize that if we're able to move those, it'll keep people going in that direction. That so often folks, as they get older, get this sense of feeling overwhelmed by their items. And we found that if we can get people to a place where they feel like they can start on their own, right? That it's something that it's not unmanageable, that they're able to keep maintaining that behavior of sorting and discarding. And how effective is this over the long term? I mean, do you have the opportunity to go back
甚至在六个月后也是如此。但就更长远的长期来看，我想我会向任何收听节目且负责资助优先事项的人发出呼吁。长期资金将是一件极好的事情，因为这就是我们能否不仅在短期内帮助人们，而且在他们的余生中帮助他们的问号。我们在另一方面知道的是，通常在缺乏实际循证治疗的情况下，囤积是如何得到治疗的，那就是进行清理，对吧？所以如果某人已经到了他们的房屋被城市或州认为不适合居住的地步，他们会进来把所有东西都拿走。研究表明，这基本上与在龙卷风中失去家园的创伤程度相同，对人们来说，这是一次非常急性、深刻的创伤经历。无论如何，他们往往会在几个月内重新弄乱家庭环境。所以这不是一个长期的干预。
in six months and see whether the person is in the same place or is reverting or has progressed? That is a wonderful question. And I wish I could tell you the answer. So for the intervention I'm looking at specifically, we haven't yet been able to do follow up. But for other interventions for hoarding, we do know that they can be pretty steady. about six months later even. But in terms of those longer long terms, I guess I'll put a call out if anyone listening is in charge of funding priorities. Long-term funding would be a wonderful thing to have because that is the question of are we able to help people not just in the immediate term, but for the rest of their lives? And what we do know kind of on the other side of it is that often how
这也印证了对我们的一些听众来说的想法，如果你有一个家庭成员，你认为他患有囤积症，你当时能做的最糟糕的事情就是走进房子说：“妈妈，我要把这一切都扔掉，就这样，我受够了。”是的。甚至还有一些人在加州专门研究以同情为基础的疗法。所以我想，如果你在那里寻找帮助你生活中的某人的方法，试着成为那张白纸，试着进来真正帮助他们思考他们想要什么，是如此重要，以至于我认为让某人告诉你没关系是非常有价值的，对吧，保留东西没关系，现状如何没关系，这给了你释放说也许
hoarding gets treated in the absence of actual evidence-based treatment is that do clean-outs, right? So if somebody's gotten to the point that they're, you know, the city or the state kind of deems that their home is unlivable, they're going to come in and take everything away. And what research shows is it basically is the same level of trauma as losing your home in a tornado, that it's a very acute, deep traumatic experience for folks. And they tend to reclutter the home environment within about a few months anyway. So it's not a long-term, intervention. Which speaks to the idea for some of our listeners where if you have a family member who has,
那么摆脱这个是没问题的，但作为人类，当人们告诉我们该做什么时，我们往往非常反感，我知道我当然是这样。所以我认为采取这种动机访谈方法完全是为了指导某人而不是指挥他们，让他们设定自己的优先事项。我想谈谈围绕囤积症的污名化。你如何看待媒体的描绘，比如节目《囤积者》或有时在新闻中看到的一些达到危机比例的报道？是的，我认为这有两面性。
you think, a hoarding disorder, the worst thing you could do then is to walk into the house and say, I'm throwing all this away, mom, that's it, I'm done with this. Yes. There's even some folks out in California looking specifically at compassion-focused therapy. So I think the more, if you're out there looking to help someone in your life, trying to be that blank slate, trying to come in and really help them think about what they want. is so important that I think there's something very valuable to having somebody tell you it's okay right it's okay to keep things it's okay how it is and that gives you the freedom to say maybe
一方面，我认为它有助于让人们更加意识到囤积的存在，对吧？这通常是一个非常隐蔽的事情。但在另一方面，我认为它非常疏离。我觉得这就好像我们只把抑郁症谈成自杀一样，对吧，这是当人们非常非常沮丧时可能发生的非常极端的事情。而囤积和抑郁症一样，存在于一个连续体中。所以有些人看起来像节目中的人，那些是非常真实的人。但也有一些人，你知道，你可能最初走进他们的家，它可能
then it is okay to get rid of this but as people we tend to be very reactive when folks tell us what to do I know I certainly am and so I think taking kind of this so the motivational interviewing approach is all about guiding somebody but not directing them and letting them set their priorities. I want to talk about the stigma that surrounds hoarding disorder. What do you think of the media portrayals and, say, the show, hoarders or some of the coverage that we might see sometimes on the news when it reaches a crisis proportion? Yeah, I think there's kind of two sides to that.
看起来不是一个问题，因为他们隐藏了其中的一部分，但它仍然可能是非常失调的。我认为这些节目让那些处于囤积中度和轻度倾向的人更不可能站出来接受治疗，因为他们认为，嗯，我跟那些节目不一样。通常当我试图为我的研究招募人员时，我尽量不用“囤积”这个词，因为围绕它有太多的污名，所以我尽量只谈论高水平的杂乱，对吧，杂乱造成的机能失调。我认为这些节目没有被经常讨论的另一面是，它们实际上对那些人非常剥削，对吧？
And the one side, I think it's helped make people more aware that hoarding exists, right? It's often something that can be very hidden. But on the other side, I think it's been very othering. that I think of it like if we only talked about depression as suicide, right, which is a very extreme part thing that can happen when folks are very, very depressed. And whereas hoarding similarly as depression exists across a continuum. So there are folks who look like the people in the shows, like those are very real people. But there's also folks who, you know, you might initially walk into their home and it might
那些人正在经历一些严重的心理健康问题，并且可能正处于寻找某种干预方式的尽头。所以我想我对节目的最后想法是，我希望它们没有发生，因为我认为它既不是对囤积的良好描绘，最终对那些人也没有帮助。大多数患有囤积症的人甚至承认这是一个问题吗？所以这是我们在谈论洞察力水平时经常讨论的事情。实际上在DSM中，其中一个细化说明是洞察力是好的、一般的还是完全缺失的。
not seem like an issue because they've hidden parts of it, but it can still be very dysfunctional. think the shows have made people who are on more of the moderate to mild side of hoarding less likely to come forward for treatment because they think, well, I'm not like those shows. That oftentimes when I'm trying to recruit for my studies, I try to not use the word hoarding because there's so much stigma around it that I try to just talk about high levels of clutter, right, dysfunction from the clutter. And I think the other side to the shows that isn't talked about a lot is they're actually very exploitive of those people, right?
我在与我合作过的人身上看到的是，他们通常能够承认杂乱是有损害的，对吧？他们说，你知道，甚至就像因为我家里的杂乱，我女儿不让孙子孙女来这样简单的事情，对吧？他们认识到杂乱存在着非常真实的生物社会后果，但杂乱与导致杂乱的行为之间往往存在脱节，对吧，有一种我想保留这些东西的感觉，却没有意识到如果你保留每一张纸，你知道，每一个水瓶，你就会有那种杂乱。所以我们试图做的很多工作是帮助人们思考，你知道，你需要多少水瓶，对吧？
Those are people that are having some severe mental health problems and are probably at kind of the end of the line of trying to find some way to have an intervention. And so I guess my final thought on the shows is I wish that they hadn't happened because I don't think it's either a good portrayal of hoarding, nor is it ultimately helpful for those people. Do most people with hoarding disorder even recognize it as a problem? So it's something we talk a lot about in terms of the level of insight. So actually in the DSN, one of the specifiers is whether the insight's good or fair or entirely absent.
并提出那种先验。所以在我们甚至开始把所有的水瓶收集起来之前就说，你生活中需要多少个？然后人们可能会说，我需要4个，我需要10个，我需要20个。然后他们把它们全部收集起来，然后他们说，哦，我有比那多得多得多的东西，我想。也许我能把这些放手。这是一个重要的点，因为我认为对于我们的听众来说，如果你，例如，认识某人，你认为他患有囤积症或可能处于边缘，
And what I've seen with the folks I've worked with is that they're often able to acknowledge that the clutter is impairing, right? That they say that, you know, even just something as simple is because of the clutter in my home, my daughter won't let the grandkids come with it, right? that they recognize that there's very real biosecocial consequences to the clutter, but there's often a disconnect between the clutter and the behaviors that lead to the clutter, right, of the sense of I want to hold on to these things and not realizing that if you hold on to every paper, you know, every water bottle, that you're going to have that clutter. And so a lot of what we try to work with is helping people to think about, you know, how many water bottles do you need, right?
你如何帮助他们，对于一个外行人来说，你做什么？你如何接近他们以让他们可能停下来？我想我总是说的一件事是，如果你试图干预某人的任何行为，选择你的时间，对吧？你不想在你们可能已经为此争吵过的时候谈论它，这不是这样做的时候。你想在你们两个人都感到平静的时候接近某人，对吧？可能不是在深夜，而是在清晨。这一天，少从你做错了什么的角度谈论它，多从我为你担心并提供帮助的角度谈论它。我认为亲人可以提供帮助的方法之一是成为那个富有同情心的存在，主动提出，嘿，如果我每周来一次，每月来一次，我们整理阁楼里的一个盒子怎么样？我真的试图鼓励人们不要说这
and to come up with that sort of a priori. So before we even start to get all the water bottles together to say, how many for you do you need in your life? And then folks might say, I need four, I need 10, I need 20. And then they get them all together and they go, oh, I have way more than that, I suppose. Maybe I will be able to let these go. That's an important point because I think for our listeners, if you, for example, know someone who you think has hoarding disorder or maybe is on the verge,
不是一个周末就能解决的问题，对吧？你不是在一个周末填满了一个房子的。你是在一生中填满它的。所以你要一点一点地清理杂乱。我经常看到的是人们说，好吧，我这个周末要去我父母家。我们要检查那个阁楼里的每一个盒子。他们的父母可能会同意。他们上去了，他们看到了将要付出多少努力。这是完全压倒性的。所以他们直接崩溃了。他们说，我做不到。这变成了争吵。没有人谈论它。一年内再也没有人谈论它。总而言之，我认为咬文嚼字的小块、来自同情之心的态度是这其中的关键部分。现在，我想对于我们许多人来说，当我们想到囤积症时，
How can you help them, just for a layperson, what do you do? How do you approach it with them in order to get them to maybe stop? I think one of the things I always say if you're trying to intervene with somebody about any behavior is choose your time, right? That you don't want to talk about it at a time that maybe you were already fighting about it is not the time to do it. You want to approach somebody when both of you are feeling calm, right? That it's maybe not late at night, but maybe early. the day and talk about it less from you're doing something wrong and more of a I'm concerned about you because an offering to help. And I think one of the ways loved ones can help is to be that compassionate presence of offering to say, hey, what if I come by once a week, once a month, and we sort through one box in the attic that I really try to encourage folks to not say that this
我们想到成堆的东西，但有些人收集动物，对吧？这难道不是同一种疾病的另一种表现吗？绝对是。而且动物囤积比物品囤积更难研究，部分原因在于它可能是一种犯罪活动，对吧？如果你被发现虐待动物，如果你有太多的动物无法照顾，这往往会发生，这也是动物囤积的定义，你将非常不愿意与别人谈论这件事，因为你会害怕他们会带走你的动物。所以我们发现的是动物囤积的另一面是人们出于各种原因拥有大量的动物。所以有一些，所谓的坏演员在那里做我们所谓的无选择繁殖动物来出售，对吧？
isn't going to be a weekend solution, right? You did not fill up a home in a weekend. You filled it up in a lifetime. And so you're going to want to declutter it bit by bit. It's something that I see so often is folks say, okay, I'm going to go to my parents home this weekend. We're going to go through every box in that attic. And their parents might agree to it. And they get up there, they see how much it's going to be. And it's entirely overwhelming. So they just shut down. And they say, I can't do this. It turns into a fight. And nobody talks about it. And nobody talks about it again for a year. So all to say, bite-sized pieces coming from a place of compassion, I think, are the key parts to this. Now, I think for a lot of us, when we think of hoarding disorder,
有点像幼犬加工厂。但另一方面，他们是我们倾向于看到的，我们称之为动物囤积的人，往往是那些再次出于利他主义的人。在他们的脑海里，他们是在拯救这些动物。我想他们中的许多人一开始都是真正的营救，
we think of piles of stuff, but some people collect animals, right? Isn't that another manifestation of the same disorder? Absolutely. And we, animal hoarding is trickier to study than object hoarding in part because it can be a criminal activity, right? that if you are found of abusing animals, which can tend to happen if you have too many animals to care for, which is the definition of animal hoarding, you're going to be really reticent to talk to somebody about that, because you're going to be afraid they're going to take away your animals. So what we have found is the other side of animal hoarding is people have large amounts of animals for various reasons. So there are some, quote, bad actors out there who are doing what we call indiscriminate breeding of animals to sell them, right?
但再次，随着年龄的增长，也许你照顾这些动物的能力变差了，对吧？或者人们倾向于知道，哦，你知道，路边的莎莉是你可以带流浪猫去的人。所以莎莉也许能照顾8只猫，但突然人们不断给她带猫，她又不想拒绝，结果她养了20只。所以我想，再次强调，这可能有点像滑坡，人们不知道该如何摆脱它。你有没有用你的技术为有动物囤积问题的人做过任何工作？所以我自己没有，但实际上我怎么开始进行动机访谈是因为在英国有一位女性在英国使用动机访谈来帮助马匹囤积。所以在大洋彼岸，人们显然有太多马匹的大问题。我想，谁知道呢？对吧？就像，我谈论文化差异。但我想如果它足以帮助人们丢弃马匹，它肯定对物品也有帮助。而且确实如此。那你怎么会对这个课题作为研究领域感兴趣呢？这完全是个巧合。这就是我应该有一些精彩的故事来讲述它是如何发生的。
of kind of the puppy mills. But on the other hand, they're what we tend to see, what we would call animal hoarding, tend to be folks who, again, are doing it from a place of altruism. In their mind, they're rescuing these animals. And I think many of them start out as a true rescue,
但事实是，我要去读研究生。我知道我想研究焦虑症和老年人。我最终进入了圣地亚哥的一个实验室，与凯瑟琳·艾尔斯（Catherine Ayers）合作，她是一位在那里的临床心理学家，从事焦虑和囤积的研究。我只是爱上了这个话题。在她早期的研究中发现的一件事是，仅仅通过干预囤积，仅仅通过帮助人们减少杂乱，他们生活中的其他一切似乎也变得更好了。所以人们的焦虑和 depression（抑郁）水平下降了，即使我们什么都没做
but again, as they get older, maybe you're less able to take care of these animals, right? Or folks tend to know of, oh, you know, Sally down the way is something you can bring stray cats to. And so Sally might be able to take care of eight, cats, but suddenly people keep bringing her cats and she doesn't want to say no, and she ends up with 20. And so I think, again, it can be a bit of a slippery slope where folks don't know how to get out of it. Have you done any work using your technique for people who have an animal hoarding
这是为了干预焦虑和抑郁。对我来说，这感觉非常有力，我们可以有一些完全是行为干预的东西，似乎只是提升了人们的生活质量。那么你现在在研究什么？这个领域中大的、尚未解答的问题是什么？是的，所以我会继续研究动机访谈的干预，但实际上今年夏天，他们将启动一个远程医疗的试点版本，看看，好吧，我们知道它在进入人们的家中时运作得相当好，但我们能否通过远程医疗获得同样的影响，对吧，通过人在家里但临床医生不在
issue? So I haven't myself, but actually how I got into motivational interviewing was because there's a woman in Great Britain in the UK who was using motivational interviewing to help with equine 40. So across the pond, there's apparently a big issue with folks having too many horses. And I figured, who knew? Right. Like, I talk about cultural differences. But I figured if it was good enough to help folks discard horses, it would surely be helpful for objects. And it has been. So how did you get interested in this topic as an area of study and research? It was entirely by coincidence. This is where I should have some wonderful story about how it happened.
问题所在？所以我自己没有，但实际上我接触动机式访谈是因为英国有一位女士在用动机式访谈来帮助处理马匹相关的问题。所以在大西洋彼岸，显然存在人们养了太多马的大问题。我想，谁知道呢？对吧。就像我谈到文化差异一样。但我想，如果它能很好地帮助人们处理掉多余的马匹，那对物品也一定会有帮助。事实也确实如此。那么你是怎么对这个研究和研究领域感兴趣的？完全是个巧合。这里我本该讲一个关于它是如何发生的精彩故事。
But the truth is, I'm going to grad school. I knew I wanted to study anxiety and older adults. And I ended up getting into a lab at San Diego working with Catherine Ayers, who's a clinical psychologist out there who does anxiety and hoarding. And I just fell in love with the topic. And in part of one of the things that she found early on in her research is that by just intervening on 40, by just helping people have less clutter, everything else in their life seemed to get better too. So folks' levels of anxiety and depression went down, even though we did nothing
但事实是，我要去读研究生。我知道我想研究焦虑症和老年人。最后我进入了圣地亚哥的一个实验室，和凯瑟琳·艾尔斯一起工作，她是一位研究焦虑和囤积症的临床心理学家。我一下子就爱上了这个课题。她早期的研究发现之一是，只要对囤积行为进行干预，只要帮助人们减少杂物，他们生活中的其他一切似乎也都变好了。因此，人们的焦虑和抑郁水平下降了，尽管我们没有做任何
that was meant to intervene on anxiety and depression. And to me, that just felt so powerful that we could have something that's an entirely behavioral intervention that seems to just raise up people's quality of life. So what are you studying now? What are the big, unanswered questions in this area? Yes, so I'm continuing to look at the intervention of motivational interviewing, but I'm actually this summer, they're going to start up a telehealth pilot version of it to see, okay, we know that it's working pretty well in going into folks' homes, but can we get that same impact through telehealth, right, and through the person's in their home but the clinician isn't and
旨在干预焦虑和抑郁的事情。对我来说，这感觉太有力量了，我们能有一种完全是行为干预的方法，似乎就能提升人们的生活质量。那么你现在在研究什么？这个领域有哪些重大、未解的问题？是的，我仍在继续研究动机式访谈的干预作用，但实际上今年夏天，他们将启动一个远程医疗的试点版本，来看看，好吧，我们知道它在走进人们的家中时效果相当不错，但我们能否通过远程医疗达到同样的效果，对吧，通过人在家中而临床医生不在现场的方式
to see like how powerful is part of it having the person just there to talk to, or is there something about having the person in your home? So I'm excited to see where that goes. Well, this has been very interesting, Dr. Dojo. I really want to thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
看看仅仅是有一个人坐在那里陪你聊天有多大作用，或者说把这个人请到家里来有什么特别之处？所以我很高兴看到这个领域未来的发展。好的，多乔博士，今天的访谈非常有趣。非常感谢您今天能来。非常感谢邀请我。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 以及其他各大播客平台上收听《心理学热线》往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的节目，请关注我们并留下评价。如果您对未来的播客节目有任何意见或想法，欢迎发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org 与我们联系。
Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards.
《心理学热线》由李·韦纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。在拉尔夫超市（Ralph's）享受更多省钱方式，例如每个过道都有的超低价。下载拉尔夫超市应用程序，每周还能通过数字优惠券获得更多折扣。此外，您还可以赚取燃油积分，在加油站每加仑最高可省 1 美元。在拉尔夫超市，您每次购物都能享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。凭借各种优惠和奖励，每天轻松省大钱。
Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. See site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拉尔夫超市服务南加州超过 150 年。各州省钱优惠可能有所不同。燃油优惠受相关条款限制。详情请参阅网站。本集节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。